[SPEAKER_02]: Evening of the 6th of Wealsun, after two and a half days at sea, the boat finally comes into visibility of the Isle of Redshore.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's evening time.
[SPEAKER_02]: The sun is going down in the west.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what you see as you sail towards the bay is frightening to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Having known the efficiency of the docks of the harbor at Monmurg, this is exactly the opposite of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifty merchant ships, some of them not even moored correctly, some drifting, sent in the bay off Red Shore, which looks like it has enough dockage, steerage, to maybe take five a day, if that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Monmurgian, not Monmurgian, Keoland warships, three of them, act like lions keeping the sheep inside their pen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically anchored off, making sure that none of them can go away.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's obvious to you, these people are prisoners, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me a little more than you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm still asleep all the way up now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to be up?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd like to be up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we're coming in.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of us will get him up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wake up, Merrick!
[SPEAKER_02]: It says, basically, Owen steers the boat through several of these ships.
[SPEAKER_02]: Coming far too close for you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: He actually is obviously a good captain.
[SPEAKER_02]: He knows what he's doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you guys pass traitors that are from
[SPEAKER_02]: Far different lands than you've been, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: These ships are a normal sight in Monmurg, but you see them here as almost alien.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as you pass by the ships, you look at the people that are crewed on them and you can see worry in their faces.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously,
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't want to be here.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not a good scene for them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, Owen, as you guys travel past, goes, look at their faces.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they're going to be ripe to sell.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is how we make the coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Slavery owned?
[SPEAKER_02]: Slavery?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: They just want to get rid of their goods.
[SPEAKER_02]: They'll do it for cut-rate prices.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then we take it to Monmurg, we mark it up twice.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it normally would be, that's the deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's how we make our money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirty minutes go by, and he navigates the ship into a small little dock on the far eastern side of the island, basically on the very edge, and yells down to Tyrus, Tyrus, Gouge, tie us off when we come in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Throwing some ropes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You throw ropes over the moors and the posts of this thing and tie the boat off and the docks rickety.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like everything in Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_02]: The island itself is
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say kind of barren.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's maybe an island eight miles long and two miles wide and Red Shore City is on the northern side of it next to the beach that stretches all the way up and down.
[SPEAKER_02]: On the other end of the island there's a castle supposedly that the Earl of Red Shore is but that's out of sight where you're at right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: The thing that you notice the most though is the stench.
[SPEAKER_02]: With smells of rotting whale flesh.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the rendering plants that take the blubber from the whales and burn it down into oil.
[SPEAKER_02]: This isn't the part of the season that they're doing that, thank God, because the smell would be a lot worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the remnants of that industry are still there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can tell that as the summer gets hotter, it just gets worse and worse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why don't you step on this deck, guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm stuck.
[SPEAKER_03]: These...
[SPEAKER_03]: Were these cargo vessels that were captured that are being forced to do this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that what it is?
[SPEAKER_03]: If it's not slavery that we're in the people's faces, were these just regular cargo ships that were supposed to be on port that were... Are you asking me or are you asking yourself?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm asking myself.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I know this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so let's go back to the original lore, what's happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Monmurg...
[SPEAKER_02]: Is being blockaded by the Dig of Grasel.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he is directing all the ships that normally would go to Monmurg to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_03]: But these are the ships that are...
[SPEAKER_03]: So they're being directed there, and they're like, wait, wait, wait, wait, we don't want to go, no, you're going there?
[SPEAKER_03]: So they're like, what the fuck, we're trying to unload at Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you're not.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're like, well, where's the Monmurgian Navy?
[SPEAKER_02]: It would come out here and bust these guys because the Monmurgian Navy is stronger than the Keoland fleet.
[SPEAKER_02]: For some reason, the Monmurgian fleet has not been able to come out and break the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Monmurgian fleet was blocked by all the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_01]: They couldn't get anywhere near any of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the sahuagin are gone now, so why aren't they out?
[SPEAKER_02]: The sahuagin were never a part of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's that you knew of.
[SPEAKER_01]: We assumed that they were the ones why we couldn't get our Navy out, they were attacking our ships.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's have a conversation about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is strange.
[SPEAKER_02]: Think about what's happened over the last... Yeah, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to ask Owen Black?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm going to bring up this conversation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why aren't...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know why Lord Jameis isn't sallying forth and defeating the Keogs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, this whole area could be emptied.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten Corsairs could do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: They only have three men of war there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perhaps he's a coward.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a coward now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, listen to what Folsom said in his song.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why is it that you think, Folsom, that Monmurg fleet isn't sallying forth and
[SPEAKER_00]: Breaking the Blockade.
[SPEAKER_04]: I honestly forgot what my song was, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Your song and your shit-talking?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your shit-talking song?
[SPEAKER_04]: But... Well, I...
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe they're not going because of some... O Monmurg, you're a jewel on display, but your leaders have led you astray.
[SPEAKER_02]: Princes and plars in their gilded halls can't see the writing on your walls.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Duke of Gratzel's noose will bind, but it's your own leaders who are truly blind.
[SPEAKER_02]: O princes of the sea, what have you done?
[SPEAKER_02]: Your squabbles and schemes have blocked out the sun.
[SPEAKER_02]: While you bicker and fight, and the city's in plight, and the Duke of Gratzel laughs while you fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Navy's stronger, so they say, but storms and whispers have led astray.
[SPEAKER_02]: The enemy's fleet, the weaker and slow, has somehow managed to steal the show.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it magic or treachery?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who can tell?
[SPEAKER_02]: But incompetence might be the cause as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The traders are stuck, the markets are bare, and the people of Monmurg are in despair.
[SPEAKER_02]: The prince of Burghoff, with his meager supply, leaves you to wonder, is this goodbye?
[SPEAKER_02]: So here's to the leaders, the princes and plars, who turn Monmurg's fortune into scars.
[SPEAKER_02]: While you play your games, the city's in pain, and the Duke of Gratzel wins again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, Monmurg, your fate's in their hands, but it's their own folly that tightens the bands.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come on, you literature.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've got science and math.
[SPEAKER_02]: Chemistry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go to the chart room.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do we have to talk about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's obvious that Monmurg has lost its power.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can make money off this.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to follow the money, that's where it goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come this way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, you guys walk down the pier and Owen keeps talking to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll love the charter room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge, great place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Man like you, rough and tumble.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, Gouge broke my nose.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lucky shot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you remember that night?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't think so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: As we're walking around the dock, yeah?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just, I do a, you know, look around, watch the waters.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again, just to see if I, is there something, I don't notice anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, what you notice is the sun's going down and it's a city that's
[SPEAKER_02]: They've got markets all over the place.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're trying to basically simulate the grand market on this stretch of beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's better for hauling up whale carcasses than actually trading.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are people trying to trade and to show their wares, but they can get maybe like one one-hundredth of their stuff off a day.
[SPEAKER_02]: All of their goods are going to waste.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can tell the faces of the traders are not happy with what they're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But basically Owen is pointing to people and saying, I'll be back, we'll go deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: He walks up the beach to this
[SPEAKER_02]: You can call it a bar, but it's pretty much a ramshackle put-together thing using driftwood and other hole.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kind of on the beach, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And there are chairs in it, wicker chairs in it, things like that, and kegs just set up in the middle of the room, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And Owen comes in and goes, this is the chart room.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he points to the wall, and there's like a chart of the sea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any military presence on the beach?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see any marines?
[SPEAKER_02]: Keog marines on the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: This place is just kind of a mishmash of people walking around.
[SPEAKER_01]: So really it's just these three ships that are keeping these merchants out?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there any red-eye?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you say that to Owen?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sure there's a red-eye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go to the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna go talk to some merchants.
[SPEAKER_02]: The four of you stay here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be back later.
[SPEAKER_02]: See what I can buy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, before you go, I do want to tell of a certain song that I wrote about Sir Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
[SPEAKER_04]: Round of Ale for the song.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's all about you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Round of Ale.
[SPEAKER_02]: Round of Ale.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll even grab it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you go and put your thing down?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I step my two flaps down and tell them to refill it with red eyes.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's just like a room full of just like caves.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like a driftwood kind of half-assed bar thing on the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's some riffraff here.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's obviously some Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rats in the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: This far north, obviously, Owen Black is not the only smuggler in this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, other pirates, obviously people from Monmurg as well, who are, it's like a, it's like, you know, take all the riffraff from the Mediterranean stick mumble.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's kind of what this is, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Everyone made the Monmurgian run in less than 12 parsecs.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lost I sleep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I put my feet up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there like a bar bar?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bartender behind it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I ask Owen loudly, I'm like, do I have the permission to tell of the worthy tales of Owen Black to this fine establishment?
[SPEAKER_02]: Rounds for everybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: My friend here is going to sing you a song, a good one.
[SPEAKER_04]: I stand on the bar with Ale in hand.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys ready for this shit?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Say, Owen Black, the finest sailor on the sea, to glide across the seas of principalities.
[SPEAKER_04]: None is better than he.
[SPEAKER_04]: The man with courage to sail the Dragon Isle, he can sail for miles and miles and miles.
[SPEAKER_04]: A true pioneer of his craft, making a galleon look as easy to maneuver as something as simple as a raft.
[SPEAKER_04]: He makes sailors like
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick, look like they can't sail those way out of a burlap sack.
[SPEAKER_04]: I pull out my fife and just start going crazy with it.
[SPEAKER_04]: A little fife solo.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll your performance.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen plus eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, this room has not had any entertainment for a while.
[SPEAKER_04]: Everyone claps.
[SPEAKER_02]: I finish it off by saying...
[SPEAKER_04]: The chorus, yet again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Owen Black, the finest sailor of the sea.
[SPEAKER_04]: To glide across the seas of principalities, none is better than he.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very good, Folsom.
[SPEAKER_02]: He drinks.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that was a little cruel towards Merrick.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's quite a good pilot, I must say.
[SPEAKER_04]: Humorous, Folsom.
[SPEAKER_04]: I look at Merrick and do a little wink.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that was good.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys, stay here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be back soon.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got to make some inquiries if any of my cargo has shown up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, like, look at him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He can only message me, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't talk to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm like... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was like, oh...
[SPEAKER_04]: I look at him and I'm like...
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you acquire assistance on your journeys?
[SPEAKER_02]: You've got the gift of gab.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can help me deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wonderful idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, teach the kid a thing or two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not a bad idea.
[SPEAKER_04]: I turn and look at Merrick and use message again.
[SPEAKER_04]: This can be read aloud.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just gonna say, I don't really
[SPEAKER_04]: Talked poorly of you because you told me to.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that was it.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then, is Owen like, I'm assuming where we're going, it's not the nicest crowd?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you say that to him?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're in a place that's not the nicest crowd.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, he's burly.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got a strength of like 16.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: He wears leather armor.
[SPEAKER_00]: His arm was a little fucked up right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a big guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's not like a huge guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's not like this guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he's not a small guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's 6'2", he's strong.
[SPEAKER_04]: I asked him, I said, I talked to Owen and said, would we need someone like Tyrus to be a little muscle where we're going?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, no, these are merchants.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need charm.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't need... that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so the two of you walk out into the night here, and Owen starts talking to you about, I'm going to refine this a little bit more.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do like that song, but I think there's a verse or two you could probably add about my, you know, skills with the ladies.
[SPEAKER_02]: That might help you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would like that as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the two of you walk out into the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be right back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bring your 20-sided.
[SPEAKER_02]: You start walking down to the docks, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And Owen, there are a couple of guys
[SPEAKER_02]: That are Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Owen looks at you and says, hang on, I know these guns, I'll be right back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he walks over to where they are and kind of links up to one of them and whispers, roll your perception check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Plus whatever bonus button, assuming.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Owen gives the guy
[SPEAKER_02]: A coin purse, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then says like that and then walks back to you and says, I owed them a debt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Luckily I had the money that I could pay it off with, otherwise they would have beat me silly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen?
[SPEAKER_02]: He just lied to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: You keep walking down the street.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so you guys walk off into the night.